also developing tonight andrew giuliani
today formally announced
his candidacy for new york governor to
take on corrupt andrew cuomo in 2022 the
35 year old son
of former new york city mayor rudy
giuliani vowed to lead an economic
recovery heal the wounds caused by cuomo
and turn this state around take a look
new york is in my blood i've been raised
through new york
i know who we are what we can be
and where we need to go we tell it like
it is and we never
back down it's time to bring new york
back
well cuomo got it wrong put sick covert
patience positive patience in the
nursing homes covered it up
got caught hiding the data all while he
raked in over five million dollars for a
book deal
all right so we know the truth they hit
it
they hit it because they didn't want the
justice department to have the real
numbers according to that
whistleblower and the state of new york
deserves better people are fleeing
congressional seat has been lost here
with reaction now officially republican
candidate for governor of new york
andrew giuliani uh we've known each
other for a long time
great to have you it's a daunting time
thank you very much for having me i
appreciate it
yeah the the numbers the density you
know go ahead
you're right look it is a daunting task
but the truth is i think the person
who's helped the most
in this is andrew cuomo the truth is new
yorkers
businesses people who are educating
their kids parents
they realize that new york is not giving
their
them the best options to set their
footprint whether it's from an education
standpoint
an economic development standpoint or
whether it's from just
a public safety standpoint i mean sean
you're a prideful new yorker you've been
new york your entire life have you ever
seen a time
when both new york state and new york
city has had such a lack of leadership
i would call it criminal leadership i
was born listen i was born and raised in
new york i did spend
years doing you know a five-year stint
in rhode island five years california
two years alabama four years in georgia
but i was
it was like a big deal to come back and
and do television here at the fox news
channel 25 years ago
but andrew i'm gonna be honest i'm
thinking seriously i'm getting out of
here
yeah well sean all i can ask you is wait
18 months because right now
i could see why people are leaving new
york but that's why we need to win in
2022.
if we don't take back new york in 2022
it might be a generation
again before new york comes back okay i
don't want to be a grandfather
forget republican democrat for a second
okay let's look at
are we going to bring back law and order
we're going to refund the police
uh are we going to have a new york with
school choice
are we going to have the corruption in
albany cleaned up uh
yeah spell out the agenda how do you
save a state this corrupt
that's exactly right and sean there are
three things that i think apply
to any new yorker whether you're red or
whether you're blue one
we need to ultimately light the furnace
of economic development again
in new york and we do that by
deregulating something the president did
very well on a national level
and lowering taxes just creating jobs
incentivizing businesses
to start their businesses and keep their
businesses in new york
rather than down in ron de santa's home
state secondly we push
school choice for parents andrew cuomo
used to say that he was a champion for
school
choice well this last 212 billion dollar
boondoggle of budget
showed that he is no champion for school
choice he did nothing for them
while raising the utf's uh budget by 15
percent and third and most importantly
sean
we stop this war on police and we make
sure we protect their qualified immunity
we repeal bail reform and we let
cops know that ultimately we know that
they are some of the best new yorkers
in our state in our cities this is not
just a new york city issue we all know
that new york city
has seen a spike in violent crime over
the last year
that actually doubles the last couple
years this is all over the state and
sean what i can tell you is
you just wait you wait until 2023
and then we're going to have a nice big
party up in albany and we're going to
see you you're going to be happy
in every interview about legalizing weed
about sports betting are you going to be
asked
your position on abortion social issues
your dad
was socially pretty liberal libertarian
i would say
do you agree with your doubt on that
where do you stand on those four
positions
well look let's start off with sports
gambling i don't much how much time we
have
anything that's going to bring revenue
into new york i am pro that
a lot of people that i know go to new
jersey in order to actually go
and gamble why are we sacrificing that
revenue right there
for me for marijuana right that answer
has been decided by the courts in new
york it is legalized
i do not support anybody under the age
of 18 following the data
following the science as republicans are
now the party of science
anybody under the age 18 that ends up
using marijuana
they are two or three times more likely
to be a hard drug user
over that it's much much less so i think
that's something we need to consider
right there
the other two look i personally am
pro-life
i don't know if we're gonna have the
time i personally am pro-life here and i
forgot what the fourth one
is but uh i'm happy to get into it but
the truth is
sean gave me economic development it's
all about education
and it's all about um it's all about uh
crime and reducing crime so basically
social issues are not what you're
running on you're running on the economy
and law and order and
bringing in revenue and keeping people
and businesses here that's what i hear
100 sean because those apply to all new
yorkers whether you're white
whether you're black whether you're red
whether you're blue whether you're
jewish whether you're gentile
it doesn't matter sean all new yorkers
are having
terrible difficulties with economic
development
having terrible difficulties staying
safe and we need to make sure
that we make new york that center of the
world again the way that we believe that
it was when we built the erie canal
connecting the world to the rest of the
united states of america
i believe we can do it again sean and
we're going to do this question
yes fracking
i do i absolutely do just look at the
southern tier of new york
and you you tell me and see where the
values are in pennsylvania
and where they are in new york and you
tell me if you support fracking clean
fracking
the answer is i do yeah i do all right
andrew i've known you a long time i wish
you all the best this
is uh new york needs saving quick
fast they can't come fast enough they
need the cavalry all right thank you sir
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else